[Music]
ladies and gentlemen if you had told me
greg
in a few
days you're gonna be
super jazzed
about this upcoming madame webb movie i
would have gawked at you
i would have said
what the hell are you talking about you
[ __ ] but boy
boy oh boy
that damn sony train ah looks like i'm
back on board
there's so many reports coming out about
this movie right now they're different
it's more than just hey look a cool
spider-man easter egg this could be
totally awesome
or
it could be another sony train wreck and
either one i'm looking forward to it
just doesn't sound like it'll be boring
and if you're boring that's the worst it
goes like boring is the top right below
it is annoying if you are at least
entertainingly bad i'll settle man so
citizens of the reject nation
leave a like flip that thing we got to
go over the list of the characters that
are here and what the potential plot
might be because the potential plot for
this is the thing that especially has me
jazz because it could be like into the
spider verse
meets terminator which come on that
sounds great or it could be
into the spider verse
meets terminator genesis you know those
are two very different experiences and
again if half of this is true i think
i'm gonna be a happy camper here we go
speeding around these cast characters
not gonna do a big giant comic lore on
these people first one on the list
dakota johnson as cassandra webb aka
madame webb there were a lot of talks
like oh was she gonna be playing julia
carpenter because dakota johnson in
these set photos doesn't look like a
frail old lady yeah she's gonna actually
be playing cassandra webb i'm sure
you've seen a lot of imagery of her uh
so you know in the comics she's like a
clairvoyant has telepathy abilities his
ability to predict things before they
happen and of course she's connected to
a life support system resembling a
spider web
it's kind of goofy when you think about
it it's pretty goofy and just side note
you know if you're only metric for
dakota johnson's acting abilities comes
from the 50 shades trilogy aka the
greatest trilogy of all time there are
three of them right not four i don't
really know but uh i've seen them all
she's actually a fantastic actress so
i'm i'm excited for her if there's one
thing i know about these sony movies is
that when you get great actors in them
you really get to showcase why they're
great actors all right next up on the
list sydney sweeney from euphoria who is
another wonderful actress she's actually
gonna be playing who a lot of people
assume she might be playing julia
carpenter so in the comics julia
carpenter was the second spider woman
and also the second madame webb not
exactly clear which point in the
timeline we are for this character or
what they're setting up because again
got so many different characters being
introduced in here it's like she really
feels like she could be either one at
this point either way i'm excited for
sydney sweeney she's very talented and
apparently she she doesn't get paid
enough money according to some interview
that she did
she needs to get paid more she needs to
build the fence around her house because
a bunch of perverts keep stalking her so
stop it all right next up on the list we
got celeste o'connor playing maddie
franklin so in the comics maddie was a
third spider woman i love the design of
her costume obviously the qualities of
it might sort of evoke the iron spider
suit that tom holland will wear but you
know this could actually be a lot
creepier if utilized properly in live
action and her character alongside with
julia carpenter very integral to the
madame webb storyline the specific
storyline where it seems like aspects of
this movie are definitely going to be
borrowing from isabella merced as anya
corazon aka the spider girl there have
been reports they are working on a
standalone movie for this character she
uses these grappling hooks like spiders
because spiderman she also has
symbiote-like protective skin to defend
herself
here's where i was like
whoa adam scott as young uncle ben when
i heard he was in this movie my mind
never even came close to thinking this
is what it was going to be and there
were these set photos that show him like
as a paramedic uncle ben to my knowledge
has never been a paramedic so looks like
he'll be doing a very different take he
was always a helper you got to help
people that's why he helped
told his nephew to to have
responsibility but adam scott absolute
gem met about a bathroom once at an am
pm we yeah
let's leave it at that let your mind
trail off on what might have happened
and then we have emma roberts now there
were photos that were going around
showing a pregnant emma roberts now it's
being reported that she's going to be
playing a young mary parker mary not may
mary mother of peter we could be looking
at seeing a baby spider-man in this
movie when she gives birth he's gonna be
in a spider-man costume we could be
seeing a baby peter parker so with those
last two characters in mind the main
plot of this movie right now is that
it's gonna be a terminator-like film
where madame webb and all these other
spider variants these female spider
variants are protecting an unborn peter
parker who's being carried in the womb
of mary and a young uncle ben from a
threat the threat being they want to
kill peter parker before peter parker is
born and you know what i like that plot
i think the plot actually sounds really
exciting like madame webb's whole thing
is about protecting the web of life and
destiny and essentially the web of life
it encompasses all of time past present
and future and essentially holds the
multiverse together so if there's a
threat out there trying to eliminate
baby pete before he can ever exist and
become the spider-man then there could
be some serious consequences to the
multiverse so it makes sense why madam
webb would get involved and assemble
this team and said i specifically only
want women this could be a really big
threat you know we've seen some
multiverse consequences as of late
worked out fine for adrian tombs no
problem wrapped it up in two scenes in
the morbius film so you know when it
came to tom holland spider-man and no
way home there's some serious
[ __ ] there so yeah with madame webb's
ability she has the capability to
transport any version of spider-man or
spider-woman across the multiverse so
maybe this could even tie into across
the spider verse as well and as fun as
it is to like crap on sony's crap they
did produce into the spider verse and
the spider-man films and then the mcu
are technically their films so then
everything they make is crap some of
it's great and the idea of doing like a
live-action spider-verse sounds awesome
like but you know it does raise some
questions like who who will the villain
be some people are thinking it could be
this villain named moreland and the
energy vampires these multi-dimensional
villains who go after spider-man
variants that conversation was brought
up a lot around the time and i believe
daniel espinoza was the one who said
that sony wanted to deal with the
spider-man totems other speculations are
saying that it could be charlotte witter
who is madame webb's granddaughter where
in the comics where she did gather the
spider-woman together to take down a
threat it was specifically to take down
charlotte and part of the group that
madame webb assembled together to take
down her granddaughter in that comic run
was maddie franklin and julia carpenter
either villain at this point sounds like
a likely thought like i'm not even super
stoked about who the villain might be
i'm more excited about just seeing all
these fighter verse characters come
together and then also the plot
of something that is very
terminator-esque right and it does still
throw a wrench and like okay if if this
made a web movie if the earth that she
inhabits is the same one that morbius is
in is the same one that venom is in
which spider-man is this but if they
care about continuity and timelines and
all that [ __ ] which i i don't know how
much they care to adhere to any of that
it sounds like they could be sending up
a new spider-man because you know there
were those set photos that show that it
takes place in the early 2000s so if the
idea is baby spider-man in the early
2000s and then we go to modern day which
is where we have people like morbius and
venom that would mean peter parker's
already grown up and he's a spider-man
the timeline of having a spider-man
exist does make sense the question is
can it be one of the three that we've
already seen recently because toby
maguire's took place in the early 2000s
and the dude definitely looks like he's
in his 40s at least and he got andrew
garfield who doesn't look like he's in
his 20s and they already had a mary
parker in those sometimes i don't think
that matters you can just do a recasting
how even the mcu just did that with
cassie lang and then you have tom
holland who i just don't think is from
this earth could be a tom holland
variant if they want to set up a new
spider-man although i don't know if tom
holland would be excited at the prospect
of doing that i don't know either way
this film sounds like it could be wild
and crazy and awesome
i'm looking forward to it what do you
guys think leave your thoughts down
below whip whip that subscribe button
and that like button become a citizen
the reject nation haven't done so
already
i'll catch you guys soon